Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: John Ockey
Ci sono dei concetti
che vengono utilizzati soprattutto -
un po’ per pigrizia, un po’ per moda.
Uno di questi concetti
è quello di resilienza.
La resilienza è la proprietà di un metallo
di ritornare allo stato iniziale,
dopo aver subito uno shock.
Ecco che, quindi,
dopo la crisi economica,
soprattutto italiana,
tutti noi avevamo un sacco bisogno
di essere resilienti:
si andava ai convegni
degli imprenditori, delle associazioni,
e c'era appunto questa volontà
di essere resilienti.
Era "pensiero desiderante",
si voleva tornare allo stato precedente
a quello della crisi economica.
Il problema, però, è che gli individui
e i gruppi di individui, le persone,
non sono mai resilienti.
Perché dopo uno shock, o dopo una crisi,
o involvono oppure evolvono.
Non sono mai resilienti, per definizione.
Un concetto simile è quello
di "disintermediazione".
In realtà il concetto
di disintermediazione
coglie degli aspetti
di realtà molto importanti:
non prenoto più il viaggio
in agenzia di viaggio,
ma lo faccio direttamente on line;
non vado più allo sportello della banca,
ma uso l’home-banking;
non devo più andare
ad un comizio di un politico,
ma posso sentirlo in diretta,
ad esempio su Facebook.
Approfondiamo brevemente
il caso dell'home banking:
fino a 10 o 20 anni fa andavamo in banca,
dove c'erano un sacco di sportellisti:
utilizzavamo i contanti,
compilavano i moduli.
Ora, diciamo così,
la figura dello sportellista,
per una quota parte,
è stata disintermediata:
andiamo sull’home banking
e facciamo tutto lì.
Però l'home banking è un filtro:
non è nulla, è qualcosa, "Medium":
qualcosa che sta in mezzo fra noi
e quello che vogliamo fare,
quello di cui ci vogliamo informare.
E non è neutrale, lo sa benissimo
chi costruisce i siti Internet:
l'architettura del sito Internet
è fatta in maniera tale
da incentivare alcune decisioni,
alcuni comportamenti, piuttosto che altri.
Ecco quindi che, sì,
c'è una disintermediazione:
ma c'è anche una "neo-intermediazione":
un’intermediazione molto diversa
da quella tradizionale,
ma non è che non esiste: c'è, è diversa.
Passiamo dall'esempio economico
a quello politico: "Occupy Wall Street".
Ve lo ricorderete, un movimento
di qualche anno fa di giovani
che protestava contro quelli
che loro ritenevano essere
gli abusi e gli eccessi
del capitalismo finanziario.
Erano giovani provenienti,
molto spesso, da New York,
poi da tante città e contesti urbani.
Volevano far passare
il loro messaggio politico:
twittavano, twittavano e twittavano.
Però non riuscivano a finire sui "trend".
I trend sono quella sezione
del sito Twitter
in cui Twitter dice:
"Be', questi tweet, questi hashtag,
sono interessanti, stanno bucando"
Quindi, se finisci sui trend
il tuo messaggio ha ancora più forza.
Eppure loro twittavano e twittavano
ma non riuscivano a passare,
tant'è vero che ad un certo punto
si è diffusa una voce:
"magari ci censurano".
Diamo per scontato
che questo non sia accaduto -
in realtà non lo possiamo verificare,
perché gli algoritmi
delle aziende private sono privati.
Però il punto non è questo:
il punto è che c'è una scelta editoriale.
E ci dice che probabilmente,
in quel periodo,
Twitter preferiva degli hashtag
molto diffusi sul territorio,
molto diffusi socialmente.
Questi erano tutti ragazzi appartenenti
alla classe cosiddetta creativa,
erano tutti provenienti da contesti urbani
ed insomma non sono riusciti a passare
come avrebbero voluto.
È la "neo-intermediazione":
sono nuovi centri di potere
che hanno un ruolo
nel plasmare la sfera pubblica.
Quali sono gli effetti?
Uno degli effetti è quello che chiamano
il "paradosso del pluralismo".
Ora, con Internet, le voci disponibili
sono aumentate in maniera esponenziale.
Su questo non c'è alcun dubbio.
Ricorda un po' la stampa
a caratteri mobili di Gutenberg:
un'innovazione che portò
ad un sacco di libri,
un sacco di pamphlet, giornali e articoli
e che fu molto importante
perché costruì la sfera pubblica,
e il dibattito pubblico,
su cui poi si sono basate
le democrazie moderne e contemporanee.
Bene, questa sfera pubblica
viene rinforzata da Internet.
Internet, dal punto di vista quantitativo,
dà sempre maggiori informazioni.
Il pluralismo, però,
non è un concetto facile;
e Giovanni Sartori,
un grande politologo italiano,
dice che il pluralismo
non è soltanto "quantitativo" -
il numero di fonti di informazione -
ma anche qualitativo,
e lo spiega con un esempio:
la differenza fra le fazioni medievali
e i partiti moderni.
Le fazioni medievali erano tantissime:
guelfi bianchi, guelfi neri, ghibellini.
Il problema è che quando c'era
la competizione elettorale
se le davano di santa ragione;
e molto spesso,
chi perdeva finiva in esilio.
È successa una cosa simile
anche a Dante Alighieri, il Poeta.
Anche i partiti moderni
sono tanti, li conosciamo;
ma la differenza fondamentale
è che se perdi le elezioni
non vieni cacciato:
hai il diritto di tribuna,
hai il diritto di parola,
puoi continuare a confrontarti.
E questo è il pluralismo autentico:
non è "tante fonti di informazione" -
sì, è anche questo; ma non è il cuore.
Il cuore è che ci sono tante voci,
ma tante voci che non sono
delle monadi autoreferenziali,
ma che discutono, si confrontano
fra di loro, almeno in parte.
C'è quindi un pluralismo paradossale,
probabilmente, su Internet.
Perché su Internet
la quantità aumenta molto.
Ma la qualità?
Be', della qualità hanno parlato
tanti ricercatori e studiosi
americani e anche italiani.
Hanno parlato delle "eco chambers"
ovvero le camere dell'eco:
quando sono su Internet, sui social,
sulle piattaforme soprattutto,
la mia voce viene emessa
e mi ritorna indietro ancora più forte,
come se fosse appunto in una stanza vuota.
E questo perché accade?
Beh, gli esseri umani
tendono all’omeomofilia.
Cosa significa?
Che frequentiamo persone o idee
che sono simili a noi,
e questo è naturale.
Ma su Internet c'è qualcosa di più,
perché le piattaforme, innanzitutto,
hanno interesse a fare in modo
che gli utenti delle piattaforme
stiano in questo contesto
perché significa più pubblicità,
più dati da poter vendere,
magari aggregati, ad altre imprese.
Quindi l'obiettivo è che la gente
deve restare lì, il più possibile.
Quindi cosa bisogna dargli?
Bisogna dargli quello che gli piace:
se ti piacciono i cani,
ti do cani, non ti do gatti.
Ecco che quindi veniamo profilati,
veniamo studiati, anche con i Big Data.
E l'offerta che ci viene data
è un'offerta personalizzata:
una ricerca su Google
che faccio io su una parola
è diversa da quella
che farebbe un'altra persona.
Questo da un certo punto di vista
è molto bello, molto comodo;
ma per quanto riguarda la sfera pubblica
può creare dei problemi.
Qual è il problema?
Riduce l'incontro casuale:
badate bene, nella "realtà",
tra virgolette, le cose sono ben diverse.
Perché se io sono un dipendente pubblico,
e vado al lavoro la mattina,
trovo colleghi
che sono stati selezionati con un bando
per le loro capacità amministrative
e quindi io posso essere
di centro sinistra,
posso incontrare
un collega del centrodestra
o un collega dei 5 Stelle.
Magari non ci vado a bere la birra,
magari non li aggiungo su Facebook;
però intanto passo otto ore con loro.
Il pluralismo è anche
in senso qualitativo;
su Internet la cosa è diversa.
Ecco che quindi neo-intermediazione,
paradosso del pluralismo,
sono dei concetti che ci suggeriscono
che ci sono dei poteri
con cui dobbiamo fare i conti
e che hanno delle conseguenze
sul nostro essere cittadini.
Quindi cosa bisogna fare?
Secondo me, innanzitutto, come prima cosa
bisogna non dimenticare le lezioni
della filosofia politica del passato.
La filosofia politica del passato
dice una cosa molto semplice:
che il potere cambia, ma rimane;
che a spinte orizzontali
vengono contrapposte
spinte centralizzate, verticistiche.
E fare finta che questo non ci sia
non significa automaticamente vivere
in un mondo più libero,
più bello, più felice:
significa, semplicemente,
non avere le chiavi di lettura
per leggere i nuovi flussi di potere.
I flussi di potere sono rilevanti:
sono privati, le piattaforme,
le grandi aziende;
ma anche pubblici,
perché anche lo Stato ed i Governi
hanno degli strumenti di manipolazione
e anche di gestione
delle masse, e degli individui,
sempre più forti e sempre più sofisticati.
Di nuovo, però,
il passato può darci una mano,
può darci una chiave di lettura,
un modo in cui approcciare il problema.
Quello che vi propongo oggi
è il concetto di habeas corpus.
Parto da questo: l’habeas corpus
è stato il cardine della nostra libertà
e dei nostri diritti come cittadini.
Il sovrano inglese, secoli fa,
tentava di imporre un potere assoluto,
un potere di vita e di morte
sui suoi sudditi,
un potere arbitrario
e slegato dalle leggi.
Ma a nobili e borghesi
questa cosa non andava bene
e imposero al sovrano di concedere
l’"Habeas corpus": "Abbi il tuo corpo".
L'"Habeas corpus"
significa che ognuno di noi
è libero, può muoversi, è autonomo:
può essere bloccato solo in questioni
giustificate e non arbitrarie.
Però secoli fa,
quando è nato l’habeas corpus,
il potere era soprattutto fisico:
l'erario di una monarchia, in gran parte,
andava in esercito
e strumenti di repressione.
Ora il potere,
soprattutto con le tecnologie digitali,
non è soltanto fisico:
è mentale, è simbolico,
è linguistico, è culturale.
Ecco che quindi bisogna passare
da un "habeas corpus",
che resta importante e fondamentale,
ad un "Habeas mentem":
"Abbi la tua mente".
Bisogna cercare di capire
quali sono i meccanismi istituzionali,
i pesi e i contrappesi, i diritti
che permettono ai cittadini
di essere il più possibile
liberi e autonomi
nelle loro valutazioni
e nelle loro decisioni.
C'è tanto da fare.
Fino a dieci anni fa,
il diritto fondamentale,
quando si parlava di Internet,
era il diritto alla connessione,
alla connettività.
Il digital divide, il divario digitale:
c'è chi è escluso
e chi è incluso in Internet,
e quindi portiamo Internet a tutti.
Questa cosa è una cosa
molto importante, valevole ancora oggi;
ma è un po’ superata,
perché ormai con lo smartphone
ognuno di noi, con pochi soldi,
ha una buona connessione.
La sfida, ora, dei diritti
è diversa, è nuova,
e riguarda il diritto all'oblio,
riguarda il diritto alla privacy,
riguarda il diritto all'identità digitale
e alla portabilità dell'identità digitale,
riguarda diritti come quello
alla crittografia,
che ricollega agli hacker:
una cosa un po’ oscura,
però alla fine gli hacker sono coloro
che conoscono un sistema operativo,
sono consapevoli
e poi sanno dove mettere le mani,
se è necessario mettere le mani.
La crittografia è interessante
perché di default, ora, la crittografia
nelle nostre comunicazioni su Internet
non c'è, in molti sistemi;
ma questo crea nuove disuguaglianze,
non è più la disuguaglianza
del digital divide.
È la nuova disuguaglianza basata sul fatto
che c’è chi ha potere,
chi è una grande azienda
e ha consulenti che gli permettono
di avere delle connessioni,
delle comunicazioni sicure;
e c’è chi è casalinga, operaio o studente
e magari clicca la spunta sul regolamento
del social network, la prima volta,
e poi si dimentica.
E questo è un problema, è un problema.
E si potrebbe dire
che però non abbiamo,
in fondo, nulla da nascondere.
Il che potrebbe essere vero,
ma ora sarebbe curioso fare un esperimento
e chiamare la signora in prima fila,
farla venire qui
e mostrarci le sue ultime
ricerche su Google.
Ecco, forse avrebbe qualcosa da ridire.
Ma porto il concetto all'estremo,
perché per afferrare un concetto
bisogna portarlo all'estremo.
Gli ebrei, nei secoli precedenti,
frequentavano l'Europa,
si spostavano di città in città
e lasciavano dati, informazioni
quando si spostavano,
o quando facevano
una donazione in sinagoga.
Tutto bene
Finché non arrivò il diavolo,
veramente il diavolo,
con i baffetti, a passo dell'oca;
e vi lascio immaginare
cosa cercavano gli ufficiali nazisti,
quando conquistavano una nuova città.
Ecco: questa cosa qui
è portata all'estremo, ovviamente.
Però ci suggerisce un punto fondamentale,
il più importante:
che quando progettiamo le istituzioni,
i diritti, i pesi e contrappesi
non li dobbiamo progettare
pensando ad un potere buono,
sempre buono, sempre gentile
e sempre generoso.
Perché se fosse sempre così,
non ci sarebbe bisogno di norme.
Dobbiamo pensare le istituzioni,
i pesi e contrappesi, i diritti
a quando il potere
rischia di essere cattivo,
rischia di approfittare
della sua posizione.
Io non dico, con questo discorso,
che dobbiamo essere favorevoli
alla privacy e alla crittografia.
Non sto dicendo questo:
dico che dobbiamo pensarci,
che è una cosa molto diversa
e molto importante.
Io credo che la forma più alta di libertà,
e di consapevolezza e di autonomia,
sia avere la consapevolezza
della fragilità della propria libertà
e della propria autonomia.
Non è un paradosso: è proprio così.
E quindi credo che dobbiamo
ispirarci un po' al pensiero hacker:
essere consapevoli,
e sapere dove mettere le mani
e metterle, se necessario.
Dobbiamo incominciare quindi
questo percorso,
che è tutto da costruire.
Facciamo quindi in modo
che le grandi potenzialità
delle tecnologie digitali
non siano soltanto un'involuzione,
ma siano soprattutto un'evoluzione
e che siano per tutti noi
un'occasione di progresso.
Grazie.
(Applausi)